shame on shot the run game on a [ __ ]
so this is what a blimp wrecks it we
just have to nigel Faraj
who knows you know the right way to say
well man a little bit of a weird-looking
dude he finally after after the the
referendum after the vote he stood
before the European Union and he just
this has gone viral he explained in his
words as to why the brexit happened and
he sat down he educated them he tried to
enlighten them but he also made it
staying just a little bit so we want to
show you some highlights from these
clips of Nigel Farage let's roll clip 1
isn't it funny you know when I came here
17 years ago and I said that I wanted to
lead a campaign to get Britain to leave
the European Union you all laughed at me
well I have to say you're not laughing
now I love that I don't care what you
say about him but that man is a P I M P
yes nobody's laughing now spelling that
on my head you expect this segment to
get better don't like I said we're going
to have people are far more
authoritative on the brexit just kind of
like the UK with the American election
it's entertainment sorry it's been it's
been an intense few weeks this is last
week of cultural appropriation month huh
brexit good on you guys you got some
independent channel going to be
entertained this evening Suns we have
some other clips don't we have some more
clips where he sat down and he talked to
them about I mean he just read them the
riot act so let's well let's let's get
to some of the substance of of his his
comments roll the next clip but what I
would like to see is a grown-up and
sensible attitude to how we negotiate a
different relationship
now now I know I know that virtually
none of you have ever done a proper job
in your lives that was hard for getting
into it he was now is hopper getting
into a hopper okay hopper loves freedom
hopper loves free he loves freedom oh my
gosh if you've not seen this speech fool
Nigel given the Smackdown to the
European Union the globalists the
internationalist the multiculturalists
it is well worth watching we have it up
it louder with Crider calm but we want
to get to the substance of the issue
here we want to get to the substance of
what he actually had to say so we do
have one final clip regarding his
comments on trade which I think are
important for people to know roll that
clip now if you were to decide to cut
off your noses despite your faces and to
reject any idea of a sensible trade deal
the consequences would be far worse for
you than it would be for us that's why I
need the beard for that's gone that
beard is gone sorry we're gonna have our
job with terrestrial radio to get that
edited so if you wanted to know how we
felt here at ladder with Crowder about
the brexit I hope we've crystallized our
thoughts for you this video you might be
a little disturbed but this is taken
from the full weekly free podcast video
cast you can click to see the full show
down there or my face to go to ladder
with Crider comm there are more articles
than you see here on YouTube or below me
for another video if you don't click any
of them that's fine
but expect anthrax in your mailbox